Have you ever heard of Namibia?
It is officially the Republic of Namibia, which is located in southwest Africa on the Atlantic Ocean.
If you are looking for a vacation with a difference, Namibia could be the right place.
Unlike other countries where visitors have to travel by vehicles or on foot,...
...Namibia invites visitors to experience the wide expanses of the country from the air.
Because of the great distances and lacking infrastructure, airplanes are like taxis,...
...and airports are the lifelines that connect all the remote places.
Indeed, the bizarre and magnificent nature is best appreciated from above.
There are many scenic trips, locally called Flying Safaris or DuneHoppers.
For example, you can fly south from Swakopmund over the empty coastline and high sand dunes,...
...where you will come across well-preserved shipwrecks stranded during the German colonial period.
You can see large seal colonies, swarms of flamingos, thousands of cormorants and abandoned diamond settlements.